tout le monde chante avec moi,
personne dans cette famille ne veut
chanter Walley world pouvons-nous compter ce
que c'est que
c'est un tartan Prancer de 2015 mr.  Honda
d'Albanie prenons la route
Adri papa voulait que nous soyons proches et
c'est tout ce que je veux pour ma famille la famille
est la chose la plus importante qu'il y a
Sheila aimez-vous l'école cette année
c'est bon alors aimez-vous l'école cette
année c'est sérieusement ce que vous  sonne
comme un lapin tais-toi
enfin donne-lui un coup de pouce ou un
oui
quelqu'un s'est fait exploser la tête
s'il vous plaît monsieur ça fait une nuit que vous voulez
un rêve pour emmener votre famille dans le
monde de Walley ne laissez jamais ça aller ma famille êtes-
vous les Griswolds que je dis que nous appelons  c'est
Griswold Springs
c'est le copain de soufre nous devrions mettre
ce truc en pot Je ne pense pas que ce soit une source
chaude ce n'est pas une fléchette es-tu fou
nous sommes nus et couverts de déchets humains
oh allez ma chérie nous ne savons pas que
c'est humain
vous